it's been one year since Russian forces
crossed into Ukrainian territory and
waged a brutal War that's left tens of
thousands dead and upended the lives of
millions Across the Nation in a solemn
ceremony Friday President Vladimir
zielinski reflected on a year of pain
and perseverance and he saluted troops
who have withstood a year of Russia's
Relentless attacks Charlie dagada spoke
with one soldier about the early battle
that changed the course of the war
the sheer courage of Ukraine soldiers
and civilians alike has become legendary
now
and the billions of dollars in Weaponry
from the U.S and its allies has fought
the Russians to a grinding standstill
now but when Ukrainian President
Vladimir zielinski made that defiant
televised address after the invasion
began saying when you attack us you will
see our faces not our backs but our
faces the fact is they were facing one
of the most powerful armies in the world
day one of the invasion began with a
brutal firefight it would prove pivotal
early in the defensive Kiev the Battle
of hostemail airport Russian forces were
deployed to secure the cargo Airfield
not more than 10 miles from the capital
itself
they were already deployed call sign
Starsky was among the small team of
inexperienced soldiers stationed at the
airport these are Russian paratroopers
exactly but they're Elite troops we had
up to 200 men
uh on our base and here in in the
airport but uh mostly those were
conscripts uh some small amounts of
officers and we're talking like
Financial officers and people who do all
this uh stuff for the Brigade this
is essentially handful of people have
never pulled the trigger in their lives
are now facing Elite Russian
paratroopers he explained that as
sophisticated Russian Attack Helicopters
came in to land his soldiers opened fire
with their automatic weapons that's the
thing one of the surprises that morning
was that you can actually shoot down
Russian ka52 that famous uh flying tank
using just concentrated fire from your
rifles
some managed to land when ferocious gun
battles broke out that lasted for two
hours
until reinforcements were brought in
Ukrainian artillery pounded the runway
denying an air bridge for Russian forces
and Firepower
a small group of conscripts financial
officers and National Guard reservists
held off the best of Russian troops it
was there a time you thought I'm not
sure we're going to win this one
so there was no way for us to lose
because
first of all if we lose this war
uh Ukrainian nation is no more so
if Russians win this war we will be
eliminated as ukrainians
they're fighting for your existence we
are fighting for our for our existence
or and for our future a future that
Still Remains uncertain as the war
enters year two for CBS Saturday morning
Charlie dagada the Hostile Airfield your
keev
that last statement is the everything
that people underestimated was that idea
of how Ukraine would respond because
without responding they their existence
is gone yeah and you you remember what
it was like right after it started I
mean everybody was saying is Keith was
gonna it was gonna be gone down right
away yeah yeah secretary blinken said
yesterday it's it's as if someone would
come into Minnesota and take it over you
know it's we wouldn't allow that to
happen